so let's talk crypto you're very rude  about um the crypto people i don't want  to be rude about crypto people yeah if  you're a man you've made a bunch of  money on crypto though the smartest  thing you can possibly do is understand  that the traditional paths to wealth  taught you a lot about being a man if i  had to make millions the old-fashioned  way i'd have learned to negotiate how to  learn how to handle stress learn how to  work really hard learn how to network  i'd have to learn i've learned so many  things these artists don't need to learn  none of that just me i'm asked  they don't know anything so my point is  that they've missed so many lessons on  the path to wealth that wealth used to  teach this is why women used to respect  money so much not just for the money but  you knew you were talking to an  ambitious connected smart intelligent  man now you can meet a man with money  and he's none of them things you just  call group.com